i think this is much bigger than me and
this story matthew morrison is speaking
out gossip is toxic and it is destroying
our society
and we need to do better this comes
after the actor was fired as a judge on
so you think you can dance following
allegations that he sent flirty text
messages to a contestant
wanting to set the record straight
matthew takes to instagram on thursday
he shares the alleged text message that
kicked off the controversy which matthew
also claims is the only message in
question
it's really unfortunate that to sit here
and defend myself and my family against
blatantly untrue statements made
anonymously
but i have nothing to hide so in the
interest of transparency i will read to
you the one message that i wrote to a
dancer on the show
hey it's matthew if you don't mind would
love to get your number and talk you
through some things
the end
i sent this because this dancer and i
both share a mutual respect for a
choreographer that i've known for over
20 years
and i was trying to help her get a job
as a choreographer on the show
it's it's devastating that we live in
this world where
gossip rules and people's lives are
being thrown around as click bait
matthew continues blasting the
circumstances that led to his firing and
ends the video with a message for his
former co-workers
i think this is much bigger than me and
this story gossip is toxic and it is
destroying our society
and we need to do better and in no way
do i want this to take away from the
show because dance has always been a
unifying and healing modality
and i genuinely wish all the contestants
and my fellow judges all the best
this comes as it learns new details
about the scandal a source tells us
quote matthew wasn't aware of the no
contact rule and his judge's contract
for so you think you can dance the
source says quote matthew has previous
experience working on dance shows in the
uk where collaborating with contestants
was encouraged he didn't think this was
going to be an issue
so what happens now well because most of
the series has already been filmed we
may continue to see matthew at the
judge's table this is all about
bettering yourself before the season
premiere last month matthew shared his
excitement with e.t on the set i love
the show i have loved it for many years
it feels it feels good
it feels tough at times though too you
know this is a very subjective decision
so i just go and be honest with what i
see and what i what i
i can give them and and hopefully um
they take it and run with it but it's a
it's a tough job
[Music]
you